former Chief business officer for Google
X MO gaudat
has just explained
that we're all about to be
doing really weird stuff with sex robots
just think about all of the illusions
that were now unable to decipher but if
we can convince you that this sex robot
robot is alive or that sex experience in
a in a virtual reality headset or an
augmented reality headset is alive is it
real then there you go go a few a few
years further and think of neural link
and other ways of connecting directly to
your nervous system and why would you
need another being in the first place
and once again
there is that huge debate of are they
sentient or not
does it really matter if they're
simulating syntheism so well
okay does it really matter if the Morgan
Freeman talking to you on the screen is
actually Morgan Freeman or an AI
generated
Avatar if you're if you're convinced
that it is Morgan free we get lost in
those conversations of you know are they
alive are they sentient doesn't matter
if if my brain believes they are they
are let's just say this is a very
significant redesign of society it's a
very significant redesign of love and
relationships and because there is money
in it
what would what would prevent the next
dating app from giving you avatars to
date a lot of people will try it there
are more than two two million people on
replica
does it really matter
yes
oh okay never mind then it does it does
really matter he's raising these
questions as they should be raised he
says look this is going to happen very
quickly we're developing this technology
quickly he says there were two million
people on replica which I assume is some
weird modern
robot sex technology thing I'm just
guessing I don't I don't know if any of
my producers are sufficiently degenerate
please let me know in my ears if that's
what it is but he's talking about all
this technology saying yeah it's gonna
it's going to advance to the point that
from dating apps because there's money
in it they're going to give you avatars
to date and if the person seems real
who cares whether or not he or she is
real
to which I would say uh I care
and you care and and we all care because
this is not a new debate this is a very
old debate this is a debate perhaps most
famously or infamously expressed in the
question that Pontius Pilate poses to
Christ during the passion which is what
is truth
Christ says I am truth and Pontius
Pilate a cynic
shrugs his shoulders and says what is
truth
and now we're being presented with that
choice increasingly today does it matter
if you're living in lies and deceit and
Illusions so long as the lies and deceit
and Illusions are sufficiently
convincing and persuasive
does it matter that they're not actually
true
the answer is yes
it does matter because
there is such a thing as reality we
actually have a reason
we actually have moral conscience we
actually have a soul that will outlive
our mortal coil we actually will face a
final judgment and we actually have the
prospect of Life Everlasting now I know
that there are going to be some
secularists and materialists and Libs in
the audience believe it or not we
actually have Libs who listen to this
show I appreciate them very much who are
going to say no we don't really have any
of that the soul is made up and there's
no such thing as heaven or eternal life
and so it doesn't matter as long as I
can just kind of feel good for the whole
time that I'm on Earth then when someday
I die I'm just gonna go take a dirt nap
and turn to worm food and that's it's
not going to matter whether I believed
true things all that's going to matter
is whether I felt pleasure during my
life and so for those people it won't
matter to them if they're dating a real
human being or if they're dating a robot
or an avatar or a sex doll or anything
else because it's all just about them
but if you
have any even remotely sophisticated
view of the world and you recognize that
that uh unlike five-year-olds and and in
their view of the world if you have
matured beyond that and you realize that
life is actually not just all about you
and it's about other people and it's
about things outside of you and the Very
fact that we're using language right now
to communicate means that there's an
objective reality to which we're
pointing you're going to say no I don't
want to marry a robot I don't want to
marry some stupid Avatar I don't want to
do weird stuff with that thing that the
Google guy is suggesting that I do I'm
not going to plug myself into the Matrix
I don't want any of that I want reality
even if reality is moment to moment less
pleasurable I still would prefer it
right now head on over to Samaritan
ministries.org Knowles how are you
paying for your health care and how's it
working out for you if it's working
perfectly great if not then listen
closely because I've got a solution for
you a Biblical solution called Samaritan
Ministries Samaritan Ministries is a
community of Christians paying each
other's medical bills its Affordable
Health Care sharing and because it's not
Insurance there are no restrictive
networks here is how it works when a
medical need arises you choose the
health care provider that's right for
you and have a say in the treatment you
receive send your medical bills to
Samaritan Ministries and they will
notify fellow members to pray for you
and send money directly to you to help
you pay those bills it could be more
affordable than what you are paying now
and if it's the right fit you can join
anytime even today check it out at
samaritanministries.org Knowles kwles
that is
samaritanministries.org slash Knowles
knowns today right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 we are days away from the
Durbin Accords the greatest threat to
the US Dollar's Global dominance in the
past 80 years on August 22nd brics
Nations Brazil Russia in India China and
South Africa are expected to announce
the launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the U.S
dollar as the Cornerstone of the Global
Financial system you can protect your
IRA or 401K from The Fallout from this
Landmark Announcement by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold historically
gold has been a safe haven in times of
high uncertainty which would be right
now when currencies fail gold is that
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles Canon wlas to 98 98 98 get your
free info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
on text nulls Canada WLS to 98 98 98
the the part that the conservatives
don't want to Grapple with the part that
the people who agree with everything I
just said don't want to Grapple with is
sex robots are going to be really
tempting
they're going to be really do not
underestimate how hot the sex robots are
going to be they're going to be super
duper hot and they're going to be
designed by Geniuses they're probably
going to be designed by robots
themselves to appeal to every base
desire that you have
in a way that you cannot even imagine
right now
and it's going to be very hard to resist
them
in a similar way that it is difficult to
resist porn
there are
many conservatives in the country there
are many Christians and people who have
a relatively traditional insane view of
religion in the country
and yet porn uses through the roof
that the median age of exposure to porn
something like 11 years old
and
what north of 70 percent of the
population regularly consumes porn of
men I think the number is like 90
percent
well a huge portion of those men and the
population generally are going to be
conservatives and Christians and people
who
in their intellect don't think the porn
is good but who nevertheless look at it
because it's so tempting and if you
think some glittering images on a
computer screen are tempting imagine
when there is just a robot that is
designed to appeal to all of your
Sensations and your whole body we have
to think about these things now we have
to take this Google Guy seriously now
had
the American people had people in the
west taken porn seriously while it was
being developed we would not be in quite
the sexual mess that we're in right now
which you can see expressed throughout
all sorts of pathologies and ideologies
that have pervaded our society and are
driving us all crazy
and and to be fair to the American
people we actually did try to take it
seriously we passed two laws about it
with Republican and Democrat support
passed by a republican Congress signed
into law by Bill Clinton the child
online protection act and the
communications decency act both of which
were broadly struck down by liberals on
the courts so we did try we failed and
now we've got this crazy sex stuff all
over Society we've got to start planning
now everyone thinks that we've got a
we've got a plan to stop Terminator
robots from going around and shooting
all of us no we gotta stop the Honeypot
robots from coming into our Boudoir and
giving us massages and distracting us
from normal life that's that poses a far
greater risk of destroying the human
race and the future Generations then
Terminator robot which could be
dangerous too some say the world will
end in fire some say in ice boy what a
great clip that was now make sure you
subscribe ring that Bell
don't miss a single video here on the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel